hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and i what i want to
show you guys today is a quick piece of
freeware you can see up at the title
called tweak vista
or tweak vi so we're gonna do is
basically like uh tweak the tweak
software that you could find with uh
windows xp except this one is for vista
only so if you open up a web browser and
go to a any standard search engine a
popular search engine such as google and
type in tweak vi
go ahead and search it and the first
link will be total idea dot com and it's
the software
um and you can see halfway down the
website here is the download link i'm
not going to go through a download and
installation video right now but if you
do need the tutorial or the instructions
for that go ahead and message me and i
can give you a few instructions if you
like so just hit download and that will
be a direct download link you can choose
first of all your operating system and
all that and then hit the download
button
so once you've gotten the software i'm
going to exit out of this right here so
once you've gotten the software
we're going to open it up right now it's
called tweak vi uh so let's see if we
can find tweak vi in our all programs
tweak
abcd efg
pqrsd there we go here's tweak vi and um
by the way tweak vi usually does prompt
uac so if uac does pop up just go ahead
and hit continue or allow uh or whatever
else it needs
so basically we're gonna start the
freeware version here you can get a paid
version uh which offers more plug-ins
more things that you can download but
the freeware version is a pretty
complete pretty uh
pretty good version pretty free version
it's um it's pretty well featured so if
we go into this here um basically
it has on the left hand side all the
different um
categories you have for the tools that
you can use uh there are utili the
utilities
i'll just go through um
system information and tweaks
miscellaneous tweaks visual tweaks and
themes and styles and stuff like that
internet tweaks and utilities now on the
front you can see here i have installed
13 plugins and you can get a lot more
plug plugins if you go with the paid
version i'm going to go into open just
miscellaneous tweaks and you can see on
the right hand side uh that the three
tweaks that are underneath miscellaneous
tweaks so um
on the left hand side if we open up say
internet tweaks you'll see all these
three firefox tweaks internet explorer
and outlook so yeah there's a lot of
utilities that you guys can uh mess
around with here that's how i could uh i
forgot that's how i i could use auto
logon which auto automatically long logs
me into windows vista when i started my
computer so even if you only have one
account it's still
when you turn on your computer
automatically logs you in so yeah you
can also auto optimize your system and
that's only that's only uh the tweak vi
subscription but yeah there is uh quite
a bit of power in this piece of freeware
here if you want to go check it out the
link is in the description you can go
ahead and download it install it tell me
what you think in the description box or
in the comments box so yeah that's been
another hd tutorial i hope you like this
piece of software maybe you want to
check it out yourself on windows vista
and if you do like what you see here
make sure you subscribe and a lot more
tutorials hardware and software here to
come thanks for watching guys peace